my pleasure to introduce to you this
evening speaker journalist mark
Hemingway when you have a last name like
Hemingway brilliant writing skills must
be part of the deal
at least it's worked out for a speaker
this evening after graduating from the
University of Oregon with a degree in
journalism mr. Hemingway has gone on to
achieve an impressive career as a writer
now a senior writer for the Weekly
Standard he has written for numerous
publications including the Wall Street
Journal reason the Washington Examiner
National Review and USA Today he has
also appeared as a guest on CNN MSNBC
Fox News c-span's Washington journal and
National Public Radio's all things
considered he is a recipient of the gold
award journalism fellowship from the
Phillips Foundation and also a recipient
of the golden prosperity initiative
fellowship at George Mason's
University's Mercatus Center mr.
Hemmingway and his wife Molly who was
herself a journalist and senior editor
at The Federalist are currently on
campus as this semester's dau journalism
program Pulliam fellows over the past
two weeks they've met with students
taught a class on writing well two
student journalists and even delivered
pizza to the hungry collegian staff on
Wednesday night after tonight the
Hemmingway's will return to their home
outside DC and their two daughters
Evangeline & Linden tonight mr.
Hemmingway will be giving a lecture on
silence is death the demise of free
speech please join me in giving a warm
welcome to mr. mark Hemingway
sorry before I began I just want to say
my wife and I have been here teaching at
Hillsdale for two weeks and we knew a
lot of people in the Hillsdale community
and I expected good things but to say
that our experience here has exceeded
our expectations would be a tremendous
understatement in fact I was just
telling my wife that before we leave we
have to go to the bookstore and buy the
place out because I can go home and
finally advertise that I have an
academic affiliation that I can be proud
of so having said that one thing we've
also learned is that an institution as
great as this you know doesn't just you
know happen and we have been
tremendously impressed and we're
incredibly grateful for all the people
that have helped put together this
experience for us including John Miller
the head of the journalism department of
my own National Review colleague he's
just a tremendous man and I would you
know I can't say enough good things
about him and his own journalism and
writing and dr. Larry Arne again his
leadership of this place is really
tremendous and it's just obvious that
that he's got a firm hand on things and
he's got a real vision for this place
and I really look forward to seeing not
just what the school's already
accomplished but what it's going to
accomplish in the future under his
leadership and then a lot of the
administrative help around here I mean
these people are unsung heroes Margie
King and Matt Bell in particular have
done amazing work organizing things and
it really is a situation where you see
everybody at the University just working
in concert to make things happen and
accomplish things and it's it's a
wonderful thing to witness and then
finally the academic community here has
been unbelievable in terms of extending
their hospitality to my wife and I some
of the professor's here like Darrell
Hart Paul ray Corey moss
they've just been wonderful people and
we are so we feel so blessed we were
able to spend some time with them
catching up and finally I just want to
thank our students in our two-week
journalism course one of the worst
things in the world is having an
experience we are trying to teach
someone something and they are
uninterested in learning and I would say
not only this is the average Hillsdale
student student above average but these
kids certainly taught my wife and I a
thing or two by the time we got done
with our course so I just want to thank
them for working so hard especially
since we came in in the middle of
midterms so thanks again guys okay okay
get ready to get lectured I'm not sure I
should phrase it that way but let's just
dive into this so I'm a political
journalist and try not to hold that
against me but one way of describing
what I do is that I spend my days
arguing with people when you put it that
way the job doesn't sound particularly
enjoyable or pleasant and I confess that
it's often not however the debates
roiling America at the moment from the
assaults on religious liberty to the
size of America's ever-growing
administrative the state are
increasingly vital to quote Calvin
Coolidge it is important that we be
lovers of freedom and anxious for the
fray but is controversial and is even
nasty as our debates have become the
most disputing thing about American
politics is that I increasingly spend
much of my time not debating the merits
of particular candidates and policies
but having to reaffirm the necessity of
having those debates in the first place
as for needing a reminder about the
threats to free speech you do not need
to take my word for it last year
playwright and oscar-winning screen
writer Tom Stoppard observed the threats
to free speech are perilous I think it's
quite a frightening time he said
accepting a pen Allen Foundation
literary Service Award Stoppard fled
Nazi occupied check LaSalle Bakke is a
child and spent much of his career or
traveling and speaking out on behalf of
art
and dissidents in the Soviet Union in
communist Eastern Europe so his concerns
ought to carry considerable weight in
particular Stoppard was concerned about
last year's attack on the French
satirical publication Charlie Hebdo
where Muslim terrorists stormed the
newspapers offices and killed 12 people
in response to the papers blasphemous
cartoons Stoppard went on to say the
Charlie Hebdo Massacre was an appalling
body shock to anybody who cares about
life let alone literature you were left
thinking well if it comes to making a
choice here clearly one has to choose
that one should be allowed and entitled
to offend without being murdered for it
that seems self-evident that doesn't
mean one is in harmony with the attitude
or the particular instances of what is
being said and written and drawn
Stoppard is right but this point is
self-evident only if you are familiar
with the West's heritage of classical
liberalism and there's currently a great
effort underway to unmake this cultural
consensus on free speech case in point
the Penn literary organization which was
honoring Stoppard for his defensive
creative freedom worldwide last year
soon found itself embroiled in an open
revolt with its own membership who were
upset that the organization also wanted
to give a free speech award to Charlie
Hebdo indeed a number of other prominent
voices used the attack on Charlie Hebdo
as an opportunity not to speak out about
violence or intolerance but instead to
criticize Charlie Hebdo barely a week
before Stoppard made these remarks
doonesbury cartoonist Gary Trudeau was
given a career achievement award at the
allegedly prestigious George pulp
journalism awards for you younger folks
Gary Trudeau rose to fame as a political
cartoonist in the 1970s lampooning
Richard Nixon at a time when every elite
cultural institution in America was
already assailing the corrupt president
naturally Trudeau used the occasion of
his career in journalism Oh used the
occasion of his career and journalism
award to chastise his murdered
colleagues at Charlie Hebdo for drawing
cartoons that he called hate speech
went on to say that by daring to
satirize the religious beliefs of
Muslims Charlie Hebdo was quote punching
downward by attacking a powerless
disenfranchised minority but when you
have the means and will to carry out
mass executions of people you don't
agree with you're anything but powerless
there's a nice literary irony to Trudeau
accusing Charlie Hebdo of metaphorically
punching down when they were literally
shot and killed in response after I
criticized Trudeau's remarks in print my
editors the Weekly Standard received a
letter from no less than John Dartmouth
the curator of the George pulp
journalism awards the letter attacked me
personally has a quote bent for Hell
headline grabber and said I was quote
grievously misrepresenting Trudeau's
argument darton went on to explain that
Trudeau wasn't failing to defend free
speech but rather he was merely accusing
Charlie Hebdo of having quote fed the
flames of violence and caused Muslims
throughout France to rally around the
extremists I can only thank Darton for
writing this letter which both clearly
and obliviously reinforces everything I
said in the first place the notion that
it is hateful to satirize people who
hold undemocratic beliefs up to and
including the belief that it is
justified the massacre the staff of a
newspaper you think is guilty of
blasphemy just because those people are
labeled a powerless disenfranchised
minority is dangerous nonsense
indeed Charlie Hebdo routinely drew
blasphemous and obscene cartoons making
fun of Jesus and the Pope yet there was
never a serious worry that a bunch of
Christians would storm their newsroom
and shoot them all the suggestion that
Muslims throughout France should be
expected to rally around extremists who
want to kill anyone who draws a cartoon
mocking their faith is patronizing at
best and racist at worst it is it is
nearly impossible to understate how
ignorant and short-sighted the view that
modern notions of racial and class
privilege should outweigh the need to
draw a bright line protecting freedom of
speech must much less serve as an excuse
for violence perhaps in an ideal world
we'd all refrain from going out of our
way to offend but as calmness Ross
Douthat has argued even the right to
blaspheme his crucial to defend
according to Douthit if a large enough
group of someones is willing to kill you
for saying something that is something
that almost certainly needs to be said
because otherwise the violent have veto
power over liberal civilization and when
that scenario obtains it isn't really a
liberal civilization anymore
but among his peers doubt that is a
thinker of unusual clarity
I'm afraid that while journalists are
fond of uttering self soothing words
about their commitment to free speech
the unwillingness to defend the values
that enable their profession is becoming
characteristic rather than exceptional
my ongoing run-ins with a journalistic
establishment over free speech are proof
enough of that
after the Hebdo massacre many news
outlets noted that one of the
much-beloved now murdered Charlie Hebdo
cartoonists Stefan Shar Bonnie Abe was
put on a hit list in the pages of the
grimly named Al Qaeda magazine inspire
also elicited I don't expect you to know
who that is only the fact that you don't
know that name represents a major
collective failing on September under
the headline wanted dead or alive for
crimes against Islam was Molly Norris
for 14 2010 Seattle Weekly announced
that its cartoonist Molly Norris had
gone into hiding with the help of the
FBI earlier that year Norris gained some
prominence is the founder of everybody
draw Mohammed day Norris hoped that the
event would become a rallying cry to
defend cartoonists this prompted none
other than prominent all Qaeda and
yemeni-american cleric Anwar al-aulaqi
to issue a fatwa calling for norris's
murder at the time Molly Norris went
into hiding I was working at the
Washington Examiner where we published
an editorial condemning various media
organizations for failing to speak out
in her defense including the Society for
Professional Journalists and the
American Society of news editors in fact
I was the one tasked with writing the
editorial as well as personally calling
the Society for Professional Journalists
and the American Society of news editors
to find out what they had said in
defensive
mrs. Norris which it turns out was
nothing as I wrote at the time freedom
of speech and the press are in deep
trouble when the American government
thinks the best it can do to protect the
journalists from death threats is to
counsel her to go into hiding and when
the elite voices of American journalism
can't be bothered to say anything in her
defense the Society for Professional
Journalists responded to this criticism
by privately emailing reporters across
the country and saying the Islam did The
Examiner editorial was misleading was
quote misleading and most likely written
to gain headlines now where have I heard
that before that particular attack on
our journalistic integrity was even more
laughable when the transcript of my
phone called it's a society professional
journalist was eventually published in
response yet the most damnable aspect of
the whole episode isn't just that most
journalists chose to ignore what
happened to Molly Norris it's that they
are instead willfully deluded about the
truth threats to free speech four days
after Norris went into hiding New York
Times columnist lamented quote the venom
on the airwaves equated Muslims with
terrorists Muslims are one of the last
minorities in the United States that it
is still possible to demean openly and I
apologize for their slurs I'd suggest
mr. Christoph asked miss Norris if it's
possible to demean Muslims openly but
I'm pretty sure she's unavailable for
comment
even before the Charlie Hebdo massacre
Christoph's Muslim apology it was pretty
rich coming in the pages of a newspaper
that refused to print the controversial
Danish Mohammed cartoons when they were
the biggest news story on the planet in
2006 the New York Times justification
for this at the time was that quote this
seems a reasonable choice for news
organizations that usually refrain from
gratuitous assaults on religious symbols
after the Hebdo massacre last year The
Times once again doubled down on the
pretense that refrains from gratuitous
assaults on religious believers under
time standards we do not normally
publish images or other material
deliberately intended to offend
religious sensibilities said the paper
in the statement it gave to BuzzFeed
after careful consideration Times
editors decided that disk
driving the charlie hebdo cartoons in
question would give readers sufficient
information to understand today's story
not five months after their statement
and why they would not publish the
Charlie Hebdo cartoons The Times ran a
story on crystal fillies painting the
Holy Virgin Mary according to The Times
the painting quote caused a furor when
it was shown at the Brooklyn Museum in
1999 the 8-foot high depiction of a
black Virgin Mary encrusted with a lump
of elephant dung and collage bottoms
from pornographic magazines outraged
religious leaders the story was
illustrated with yes a picture of the
offensive painting again we see the
times regularly publishes stuff
offensive to believers provided they're
confident those believers won't shoot up
their newsroom now saying the New York
Times should be brave enough to publish
things that may invite them violence
upon itself is a lot to ask for what's
not a lot to ask for is for the paper to
dispense with their transparently
disingenuous rationalizations about why
they won't do this after the Charlie
Hebdo attack the yilan's Posten the
Danish newspaper that originally
published the controversial Mohammed
cartoons that sparked violence a decade
ago refused to publish any of hebdo's
controversial cartoons the yilan's
poston editor Flemming Rose subsequently
wrote a book the tyranny of silence
about the paper's ordeal and it is an
admirable critic or about the need for
free speech but when Rose was asked
about his refusal to publish the Hebdo
cartoons he told the BBC quote we caved
in violence works sometimes the sword is
mightier than the pen at first Blanche
roses explicit cowardice may be hard to
digest but compared to the New York
Times it's positively heroic in response
to Rose's comments Timothy Garton ash
points through the British columnist
Nick Cohen who observed if you are
frightened at least have the guts to say
that the most effective form of
censorship is one nobody admits exists
it is both sad and undeniable that much
of the Western media along with most
other guardians of public trust are
eager to self-censor
and in complete denial about it the only
question before us now is what to do
about it
we certainly didn't arrive at this place
where our great institutions were
unwilling to uphold the First Amendment
overnight I suggest to you that this
cowardice - and hostility to free speech
is the result of being learned and
taught and absorbed over generations you
can all congratulate yourselves for
choosing to attend Hillsdale but the
reality is is that higher education like
they're more responsibility for this
tragic state of affairs than any other
institution to give you just one example
of how thoroughly baked into the
American cake are wrong the critical
view of the First Amendment has become
when issues of controversial speech
arise in the news almost inevitably you
will hear someone educated person quote
Oliver Wendell Holmes his admonition
that you can't falsely shout fire in a
crowded theater no one bothers to
mention that Holmes his quote comes from
a ruling where the Supreme Court decided
that merely distributing flyers in
opposition to the draft in World War one
violated the 1917 Espionage Act indeed a
great many Americans did hard time
because good wilsonian progressives
decided that opposing the government in
public was a crime and in case you're
wondering this is the same 1917
Espionage Act the President Obama
invoked in 2015 to justify the
Department of Justice snooping on The
Associated Press newsroom and Fox News
national security reporter James Rosen I
don't think it's an accident that
Woodrow Wilson the man largely
responsible for probably the greatest
debridement of free speech in American
history the legacy of which still haunts
us was otherwise notable for being
president of Princeton University
further Wilson's pioneering academic
work and Hegelian progressivism which
represents a complete denial of obvious
truths of human nature is still the
dominant intellectual force governing
the Academy and many other American
institutions house the progressive
legacy working out for higher education
most of you were at least familiar with
the goat rodeo at the University of
Missouri last year where a professor
physically threatened the student
journalists and the inmates running
Mizzou's asylum managed to get the
university president fire but it's worth
looking at a few more of the many recent
example
of higher education gone wrong imagine
you went back to a more innocent time
say ten years ago when campuses were
only largely rather than completely
insane and posited that any number of
these recent developments were satire
people would regard these tales as
unbelievable and incredibly over wrought
two years ago the University of
California Berkeley who was celebrating
the 50th anniversary of the Berkeley
Free Speech Movement often credited with
kicking off the modern era of campus
activism romanticizing the Berkeley Free
Speech Movement too much is a mistake
but by the standards of contemporary
campus activism even the use of the term
free speech is laudable however I have
my doubts that the 21st century Berkeley
agrees to mark the anniversary UC
Berkeley Chancellor Nicholas Dirk's sent
out a memo that read as we honor this
turning point in our history it is
important that we recognize the broader
social context in order for free speech
to thrive you can probably tell where
this is heading Dirk's went on to say
specifically we can only exercise our
right to free speech insofar as we feel
safe and respected in doing so it is
emphatically not true that the right to
free speech depends on whether or not
you are in a safe space with which is a
concept that college kids like to talk
about but doesn't really exist rather at
the entire notion of America stands or
falls on the assertion that the absolute
right of free speech predates and stands
apart from any authority that threatens
it history is full of heroes and martyrs
that will testify to that were he alive
Patrick Henry with no doubt informed
Chancellor Dirk's that give me liberty
insofar as we feel safe and respected
asking for it doesn't quite have the
same ring to it
last year Yale faculty member erikak
Christakis sent an email in response to
the Yale intercultural Affairs
committees plea the students avoid
wearing offensive Halloween costumes
students reacted so poorly to her email
that a few weeks later she announced she
would suspend teaching courses at Yale
Christakis asked what she mistakenly
thought was a rhetorical question have
we lost faith in young people's capacity
in your capacity to exercise self
censure through social norming and also
in your capacity to ignore or reject
things that trouble you also last year
contrarian students at Amherst
University posted fliers objecting to
the message of campus protest sweeping a
nation that said in memoriam free speech
a left-wing student group fired off an
angry letter to the administration in
response to the students concerned about
preserving free speech among their angry
demands were that the students who
posted the Flyers about free speech
quote go through the disciplinary
process if a formal complaint is filed
and that they be required to attend
extensive training for racial and
cultural competency indeed extensive
training for racial and cultural
competency is rapidly becoming the
singular if disturbing definition for
education these days
in any event Woodrow Wilson would be
proud that his enduring academic
influence means that people still regard
posting flyers as a crime
and speaking of Woodrow Wilson students
at Princeton University caught up in the
recent spate of campus protests have
been demanding Wilson's name be removed
from campus this is in response to
Wilson's unvarnished racism and in spite
of the fact that he's the school's most
famous alumnus ok fine I confess I find
this incident more amusing than
troubling however such absurdity
suggests that the campus intellectual
environment is possibly beyond
redemption it would be a fool's errand
to beg professors and administrators to
stop propagating the corrosive ideas
they've been spewing for decades I think
the solution to preserving free speech
requires taking a different
tack so I proposed appealing to
America's students directly and asking
them to do the one thing young adults
never do and that is this please
consider your own mortality it feels
great to be young and I hope the
students here today are self-aware
enough to enjoy it but I know one fact
about everyone in this room for certain
and that is someday we're all going to
die
I don't pull it out or find out
existence to be depressing as a
Christian I would tell you death is not
the end but I also tell you this simply
because it is the truth
the ultimate point of upholding the
right to free speech is that encouraging
the robust competition of ideas is the
best way we know of to reaffirm and
accumulate truth that accumulation
happens over time and over time we all
die interestingly enough is John Stuart
Mill whose ideas about utilitarianism
have done much to undermine natural
rights who has most eloquently
articulated the generational case for
free speech Mel writes the peculiar evil
of silencing the expression of an
opinion is that it is robbing the human
race posterity as well as the existing
generation those who dissent from the
opinions still more than those who
uphold it if the opinion is right they
are deprived of the opportunity of
exchanging error for truth if wrong they
lose what is almost as great a benefit
the clearer perception and livelier
impression of truth produced by its
collision with error now a silencing
expression results in robbing future
generations of the truth then what does
this say about current student attitudes
the evidence so far is pretty
disheartening as the Wall Street Journal
recently reported the William F Buckley
Jr program at Yale recently commissioned
a survey from McGlothlin associates
about attitudes toward free speech on
campus some 800 students at a variety of
colleges across the country were
surveyed the results though not
surprising are nevertheless alarming by
a margin of 51 to 36 percent students
favor their school having speech codes
to regulate speech for students and
faculty 63 percent favored requiring
professors to employ trigger warnings to
alert students to material that might be
discomforting one-third of American
students polled could not identify the
First Amendment as the
part of the Constitution that dealt with
free speech 35% said that the First
Amendment does not protect hate speech
while 30% of self-identified liberal
students say the First Amendment is
outdated what this suggests is that
today's students are retreating from the
realm of debate leaving public opinion
to be dominated by the tyranny of
deranged minority viewpoints further if
we think about free speech in terms of
posterity these trends suggest it will
be as if a huge swath of the
up-and-coming generation never existed
if there's a blank page in the annals of
history where your name and achievements
in the service of others could have been
written what's the point so ask yourself
what's the worst that could happen if
you speak out well yes you could die but
once you come to terms with the fact
that's gonna happen anyway it's
tremendously clarifying - jarred - out
an algerian poet and novelist put it
this way silence is death
if you speak you die if you are silent
you die so speak and die - out did not
say this lightly he was killed by Muslim
extremists in 1993
I don't expect all of you to be that
heroic and for those of you that aspire
to be I would caution you not to succumb
to the fallacy that the worth of speech
is judged by the size of the reaction it
engenders but this is precisely why your
education is so important and you should
take it seriously adulthood is consumed
by difficult judgments and the struggle
to balance competing interests college
students are largely free of these
responsibilities because Society has
decided that now is the time in your
development when you should learn to
discern and express which ideas are the
most true it is even hoped that you will
learn to do this by also using the words
that are the most appropriate and
beautiful and eventually the best among
you will serve as leaders and inspiring
figures for the rest of us when
challenges inevitably arise if the last
century is anything to go by millions of
lives will depend on the ability to
speak truth when others aren't capable
but even a quiet life spent diligently
exchanging error for truth goes a long
way toward preserving freedom for
generations and that is no small
accomplishment so I reiterate that you
are incredibly fortunate to attend a
university that from what I have
witnessed stands firmly in opposition to
all of the forces conspiring to destroy
our heritage of freedom and it is my
hope that all of you blessed to attend
and contribute to this unique school can
both serve as an example and reach out
to the many other young Americans who
not only aren't being told the truth but
are being threatened the moment they
stumble across it I hope that you spend
your time at Hillsdale honing your
god-given abilities so you were up to
the enormity of the task being thrust
upon future generations but most of all
I hope that when you leave this room
tonight and when and eventually when you
leave this campus for the wider world
you do so with a renewed sense of
purpose regarding the two things that
all of us were born to do speak and die
thank you very much
thanks a bunch mark we're gonna ask you
to come up again because we have some
audience questions so please stand when
the microphone is brought to you and
make the question shorter than the
answer will probably be no life stories
thanks again mark thank you for coming
welcome to Hillsdale thank you is there
any other college or university you
could go to and make a speech like this
and not be harassed or things thrown at
you or having things whatever and and I
have another question to ask you also
the answer as far as these leftist
journalists and their willingness to let
Muslim extremists do what they do is it
because they're they are scared of them
having their head sliced off or being
murdered or is it because they admire
them because because these Muslim
extremists want to exert absolute
control over people and they and they
like that because it seems like leftist
journalists like Fidel Castro or Google
Shabbos or people like that that want to
completely control individuals thank you
that's tough I mean that's really that
the chicken or the egg of free speech
debates these days I mean it really is
it to what extent are the
rationalizations a result of fear and to
what extent you know are they just you
know completely ignorant about the
threats involved i I don't really know I
wish I could keep you a better answer
that I mean you sure you tell us
probably walking a fine line throughout
my remarks about that that same issue
but in any event what really matters is
the outcome and the outcome is we're not
telling obvious truths about what's
going on I mean people seem to think
that you know the most important thing
we do is not you know criticize you know
Muslim terrorists you know and I don't
think that it's not a difficult task
before us to say that terrorism and
extremism and murder are bad and
separate that out from you know
the Muslims who are in fact peaceful but
but the fact that they the media so
desperately want to confuse the two is
really problematic and we really need to
see what we can do to make that point
effectively Barack Obama once said the
future does not belong to those who
insult the Prophet right who was he
talking to and what was he really trying
to say and the second question is what
ever became a Salomon Rushdie that's it
that's our good questions one is it's
not just that I mean because if you the
sir excuse me
I'm much better when I have prepared
written out remarks as you can see
there's been a lot of signaling not just
by Obama personally but by the State
Department and other things in the Obama
administration where they're like wink
winking to the Muslim world where they
think that they just you know sell out
our American ideals about free speech
that will somehow get these Muslims who
are sort of totalitarian in nature and
totalitarian in the nature of their
threats to back off you know like like
somehow that is the way to deal with
that we saw after of the Benghazi
attacks what did they do they rounded up
a guy who whose crime was you know they
said it was a parole violation but it
was obvious they were arresting him
because he put up a video on YouTube
that Muslims in the Middle East didn't
like and threw him in jail and they've
done this sort of thing repeatedly and
it's all just about signaling thinking
that that you know showing that they
have some sophisticated cultural
understanding will keep these people
from killing us which as we've learned
time and time again since then just you
know it's just not the case as for
Salman Rushdie that's people forget what
a serious ordeal that was back in the
eighties I mean I think was the Japanese
translator of his book was actually
killed and Rushdie was in hiding under
security for a number of years I think
that it's been long if the threat has
died down so much but but I know the
Rushdie is still you know careful about
his security and everything else but
oh they did I had not heard that but
there been a number of other threats if
there was a British publisher that was
firebombed because they published a
novel about them from a perspective one
of Mohammed some lives a couple of years
ago and Charlie Hebdo had several
attacks before they were several it's
both attacks and threats before the
terrorists actually succeeded so it is
very much not a you know a free
landscape for people that want to say
anything critical about Islam there is a
perfect albeit ironic solution to the
problem you describe all it takes is a
successful prosecution of one test case
and results from the restoration of
Civil Rights Act sponsored in the 70s
like Ted Kennedy according to which
violation of the Civil Rights by a
university of any one department
suspends federal support of all
departments
why couldn't something like that be
tried well I know that's an intriguing
idea i I all would say this which is the
free speech is best when it is a
cultural understanding that everybody
just sort of acknowledges rather than
people litigating each other you know to
protect the right of free speech the
problem is that the unmaking of that
consensus I think you know if it comes
to that you know maybe it comes to that
but I just think that the current
cultural and political consensus the
moment you went down that sort of legal
path might end up blowing back in your
face
reaction to the Donald Trump's
suggestion that the libel laws should be
strengthened with regard to the press
because the press engages in too many
lies and too many misrepresentations
well I have a couple of reactions one is
that if we opened up libel laws the
person that might most be hurt by that
is Donald Trump he has a habit of saying
fairly outrageous things about a lot of
people I started the speech a number of
weeks ago but I actually finished it
last Saturday literally as the the big
event in Chicago was going down we're a
bunch of left-wing
protestors moveon.org which is you know
it's not some ragtag group of people I
mean this is one of the biggest left
grassroots leftist organizations in the
country and so Bernie Sanders supporters
were involved in a action to shut down
Donald Trump's campaign event which you
know it was just a horrible thing it's
you know so contrary to the spirit of
the First Amendment that you would deny
somebody a platform but at the same time
you know Donald Trump has his own issues
with free speech and so completely
accepting you know whatever larger
dynamics are involved in politics and
the presidential race when it comes to
this narrow issue of a first amendment
battle if it's a choice for the
moveon.org and Donald Trump all I could
think about was Henry Kissinger's famous
line about the iran-iraq war which was
can they both lose
mark thank you very much as part of that
Saul linski his ideas to isolate right
and then basically take everybody down
in the process and that sounds like what
the left has in mind at this point I
just wonder what your comments are
regarding that oh I think that that's
absolutely correct I was just reading a
story today about in Politico about
Michelle Obama's let's move new healthy
nutrition campaign for children and what
was fascinating to me about this article
was it treated this notion that the
Obama administration was sort of wink
wink issuing regulatory threats against
soft drink you know manufacturers and
all kinds of other food manufacturers
who you know was basically threatening
them to get on board and support this
nutrition program what else we do or
else and the way the article treated
this was just well this was kind of
business as usual in Washington and I
find the idea that people just you know
go around wielding money and power as a
means of fostering consent you know I
mean I guess technically on some level
that's legal but the idea that we're
just we see every issue as a political
one that we need to immediately polarize
and exploit is really really troubling
and again it speaks to what I'm talking
about on making this consensus on civil
disagreement you know being allowed
Oh what do you think about the threat
about the so-called climate deniers
where their Justice Department is
apparently relating the action there is
a sitting u.s. senator Sheldon
Whitehouse from Rhode Island who wrote
an op-ed in The Washington Post saying
that people who don't believe in climate
change should be prosecuted prosecuted
under Rico laws in other words they're
guilty of racketeering
he wrote this last year and it was again
another thing where everybody just
blinked and shrugged and said that you
know I mean the idea that sitting u.s.
senator is floating these ideas in the
Washington Post and you know Klaxons
aren't going off is just absolutely
beyond me and the fact that the Attorney
General was you know further asked about
this and she you know seemed to treat
the ideas if it was a legitimate one is
even more alarming but you know keep in
mind they already did this with tobacco
executives in the 1990s you know I'm not
a big fan of you know tobacco I think
it's unhealthy and you know I think that
you know maybe there isn't even the case
where it should be regulated but the
idea that you're using racketeering laws
to stop people from smoking is just you
know an appalling abridgement of you
know basic individual liberty
hello my question is other than speaking
what is the greatest safeguard to
protecting the First Amendment do you
think it's the Second Amendment or do
you think it's something else you're
trying to get me in trouble aren't you I
am a stronger supporter of the Second
Amendment in the bill of rights
generally as I am obviously just the
First Amendment so I'll just I'll just
leave that Dara but yes I mean certainly
that was one intention of this the
Second Amendment but I think to speak
more directly to say yes speaking is the
chief thing you can do and I've seen
sort of an appalling lack of spine in
this regard I think a lot back to a year
or two ago when Indiana passed that
religious freedom law and which caused
this great national freakout now bear in
mind this was based a state-based
version of religious freedom law that
Chuck Schumer and the Clinton White
House had signed into law you know near
you know with total approval less than
two decades ago and all of a sudden the
cultural consensus and left had shifted
so that they decided that all of a
sudden this thing the Democrats had
usually supported not that long ago was
you know evil and what happened there
when you had everyone from like Tim Cook
to you know the CEO of Apple and all
these other people publicly threatening
the governor of Indiana it was a perfect
opportunity for someone to stand up and
say enough and Mike Pence was a guy that
you know was supposedly this rock-ribbed
conservative and you know he folded
faster than Superman on laundry day I
and it's really disheartening what we
really need to do is we need leaders who
are put in those situations just say no
and what's Apple gonna do Apple's gonna
stop selling their products in Indiana
meanwhile they're gonna continue selling
them in Saudi Arabia where their human
rights record you know on gay issues is
fantastic no Mike Pence needs to stand
up and humiliate Tim Cook over that but
he didn't do it
and we need people to you know speak the
truth about these things
they took away from you he can't buy an
incandescent light bulb and yeah that's
everybody laughs is something like that
but that's a freedom they took away from
you that's a choice free no free
enterprise just and so if they can get
away with that there's a bunch more
they'll try to get away with my wife is
bad I so I am incredibly sympathetic to
that plight further that was also done
by Republicans I might add that was not
a democratic initiative and my other
favorite part about this is that the
compact fluorescents they want you to
replace your lights with have mercury
and other dangerous chemicals in them so
if you break one in your house what am I
supposed to call in a team of people in
hazmat suits but yeah I mean you know
there is a cavalier attitude toward
these sorts of things I mean even
Republicans to a large degree have
embraced social engineering in ways that
I find frankly disturbing like to go
back to the example I was telling you
about Michelle Obama's let's move
campaign where she's you know trying to
tell Americans what to eat well part of
the reason why we have such an obesity
problem and nutrition problems in this
country is because poor people eat
poorly because they eat the cheapest you
know most processed foods because that's
all the money they have if you want
people to eat better make them wealthier
but Democrats won't end up you know they
are wedded to redistribution as policies
that make people poor so they're
constantly tinkering around the margins
with stuff that doesn't actually fix the
underlying problem it's Democrats are
constantly promising to cure dandruff
with decapitation and I just I don't
know what you can do about it but there
definitely needs to be an attitude of
individual liberty and individual
responsibility restored but with that
comes you know people need to be
educated they need to know what their
options are they need to be able to have
the self confidence in their own
faculties to trust themselves to make
decisions and government clearly doesn't
think that they can be trusted
so where do you go to get the truth
today a the New York Times which nobody
reads Los Angeles Times they all say
that this Supreme Court nominee is a
moderate and nothing could be true
farther from the truth so where do you
go to get the truth Church but but that
is a good question the only thing I
would say here is that there's this
giant liberal fallacy Obama likes I know
it's a Martin Luther King quote but
Obama is really fond of quoting it you
know the moral arc of history bends
toward justice and while I respect dr.
King a great deal that quote is total
nonsense I mean history is full of times
where you know our cultural and you know
societal progress has been you know
turned back hundreds of years I mean you
know there's a reason why they called
them the Dark Ages you know so I find
that this notion that so we have to be
careful about a couple things one is
simply thinking that things are worse
than they're ever going to be now or
thinking that things can't get worse in
terms of the social progress that
Democrats and other progressives want us
to buy into so to answer your question
the media landscape looks really bad but
the question might better be phrased as
is it really not that much worse than it
ever has been you know there's always
been bad publications there was you know
you've always been yellow journalism
there's always been people pushing an
agenda in the news and the thing I would
submit to you is that least on the right
the state of publications is fantastic
you know obviously I feel great about my
own publication the Weekly Standard
please subscribe but natural view is a
fantastic magazine there are all kinds
of lesser conservative magazines that
maybe you are are not familiar with that
I can't recommend enough The Claremont
Review of Books is terrific
yuval levin x' national affairs
quarterly is fantastic they're the new
atlantis is this great conservative
journal that take
scientists times scientific and ethical
issues there is a lot of great
information out there but it requires a
populace that is educated and
intelligent enough to know when they're
being lied to and seek out you know
things that they are capable of judging
as being accurate and we're in a
situation where the educational state of
things is very very poor people need to
be spoon-fed and a lot of people make a
lot of money spoon-feeding people thank
you very much my question day there's
obviously a bunch of young journalists
in the audience today and unfortunately
we live in a society where the things
that need to be said often incite such
anger and I think everything the
audience would agree that when you make
somebody too mad they ignore your they
start to ignore your opinion so in your
opinion and I guess as advice to young
journalists in the audience is there a
time in which it is appropriate to tone
down your opinion or to be careful about
the language which you're using so as
you can get your opinion across
I mean if so how should that be balanced
well this is really tricky because part
of what's going on right now here is the
the late Christopher Hitchens it was a
man I
I rarely I might very often profoundly
disagreed with but one of the great
things about free speech is I can point
to this guy and say I actually admired
his rhetoric quite a bit he was a very
big public debater and he and he said
that toward the end of his life and you
do these public lectures he was
increasingly told by people especially
young people
well that offends me like that alone
constituted an argument like you know
and his and I think his response to
something the lines is like well I'm not
running for anything so I don't have to
care what you think right so I mean I
don't think obviously you should go out
of your way like I said in the speech
you know if the set of speech is really
is a big fallacy where people think that
you know just by outraging people
they've done something I would encourage
you not to do that I'd encourage you to
just you know speak the truth and if
other people can't handle the truth well
you know that is their problem
it's it's not actually yours but if this
also goes back to the education thing
which is that I read this story today I
actually read a little squib about it
for the magazine we're up in some
township in New Jersey what had happened
the two sixth-graders
one of them had been dragged before an
administrative judge who found that he
was guilty of bullying because he had
told his classmate that he that he
didn't think vegetarianism was a good
ideas classmate was at vegetarianism and
that his brain wouldn't be as smart and
that vegetarians were idiots and what's
interesting about this case is if you
actually look at the administrative
judge's ruling
well one when you found the kid guilty
of bullying as stupid as it is I can't
really blame the administrative judge
because the ridiculous law basically the
ridiculous law says singling about
anybody for any distinguishing
characteristic is bullying I mean you
know and if that's the case and that
what kind of absurdities are going to
flow from basic you know punishing
people for basic disagreement and then
further in the decision he singled that
the statements the kid had made about
vegetarianism being bad as being the
punishable statements not the
vegetarians or idiots and I just don't
know what situation we're in here where
school officials lack like principals
and teachers lack the moral authority to
tell the kid look you know you're you're
entitled to have your opinion about
vegetarianism but you're not expressing
it and very nice or civil way but
instead the kid gets dragged before an
administrative judge who you know the
waste of everybody's time to sense this
kid to 5:00 lunchtime detentions or
something over this and actually the
legal system involved and then he
doesn't in in and the ultimate lesson
for the administrative judge's decision
is not that he was being uncivil it's
that he's not allowed to have an opinion
about vegetarianism now if you were a
sixth grader and you're trying to find
some sort of Enki if you're trying to
you know develop some inchoate ideas
about social norms this is just an
entirely pernicious thing you know what
you're teaching the kid is that he has
two options either he can be completely
cowed by this and not have an opinion or
he's just going to learn to disregard
you know any sort of attempted
because you know he's not allowed to
have the opinion anyway and the reality
is he wondering why the politics and the
cultural battles in this country are so
bitter is because we for decades have
not been teaching people how to civilly
agree you know our civics are bad
because we don't teach civility thank
you